well we see homeless in just about every
part of the valley these days from the
strip to downtown shopping centers but
now there are some issues on the campus
at UNLV and that's why Mary Jane
beliesza joins us live with the safety
measures to keep students and staff safe
as well as some help for the homeless
Mary Jane
I'm right here next to the Student Union
it's a popular hangout spot among
students and also draws in the homeless
crowd
the University of Nevada Las Vegas is a
350 acre campus just east of the Las
Vegas Strip with over 25 thousand
students in attendance it can be hard to
keep track of who was on campus are we
just talk it up to being a public
university I mean anybody can really
step on campus though so but yeah I do
see a lot of homelessness sometimes here
Christian Williams is from the Bay Area
he's studying criminology and is all too
familiar with the homeless crisis but
says he does feel safe attending classes
some of those safety measures includes
an emergency call box system that
dispatches police to your location so I
think those are really good tools that
we have used to kind of help prevent you
know violence and stuff like that crime
on campus and things like that so I
think they're really good to have for
campus while the homeless issue expands
to more than just UNLV Student James
Sims says it's going to take the
community as a whole to tackle this
issue we have a couple of homeless
people that are on the campus that hang
around the bathrooms or walk around or
sometimes sit and sleep Sims has seen
the impact of homelessness in our city
after doing a ride along with Metro
Police and local organizations is there
really a homeless problem or do people
just want to be homeless because it's
easier just to do drugs and stay on the
street than it is to get help as far as
what the city can do I don't know and I
don't know where you would push these
homeless people to even if they did
something I feel like it's wrong to kind
of move people like kettle
students tell me they do have a rebel
card which gives you access to certain
buildings so they can track who's coming
in and out and according to Dr Carlton
Craig the director of social work he
says there will be several proposals
coming in the next few months so they
can actually address the homelessness
problem on campus reporting from UNLV
Mary Jane beliesa 8 news now thank you
Mary Jane in a statement UNLV says it
strives to offer safe and welcoming
spaces for students employees and
visitors this includes maintaining a
positive experience for students and
other members of the university
community community while also balancing
access opportunities for visitors to use
our campuses